hmm okay it says we are alive although I
can't see if we are actually live so let
me just refresh this should we should be
live although it says welcome back and
the high quality option should be
available now so yeah let's let's try
with that okay so I think the the video
quality should have improved now so if
you could just test that out please
to me it's now available in 720 and the
1 ATP are also in 60 frames per second
so hopefully that's that's gonna work
now
yeah it's 180 now alright ok that's that
makes me very happy
60 frames per second available all right
we're not gonna try 4k at the moment
although I think this setup could
actually withstand that alright video
called improved ok now we're we're up
for the second challenge let's go mr. ed
ed Oh Gallardo so alright video is is
fine audio is fine let's let's try the
Evans gambit if if blackwell will allow
it of course okay now no we don't yes
the dog is missing this is another place
of residence where the dog does not
reside so unfortunately there is no dog
here but you know most of my videos I
will still be doing from from my home so
it's not a problem for everyone who who
wants the dog this is only my my setup
for emergencies all right let's just
castle the safety here everything is
fine just focus yeah okay no I haven't
moved anywhere this is just my new place
where where we're gonna be creating the
the chest manga
well I will I want to say soon but it's
not gonna be soon it's gonna be fairly
soon um we're expecting some maybe three
months before some ideas are are visible
so but but you will be informed about
that no worries I'll let's try to
unlevel some points here no I I'm not
going to leave my dog behind in
emergencies by emergencies I mean when
we're maybe redoing the apartment or
something like that so I have another
another place where I could create
videos or something like that
you guys always assume the worst can I
challenge you while using Samson yeah I
guess you could do that let's grab this
guy here attack the bishop I will post
the new setup in the description below
very very soon okay let's just I guess
we could play this makes sense it's a
triple attack against f7 our is the
Evans gambit game where we're very close
to it and it's gonna be a really awesome
one okay that's a really weird move
positive Aiden was a veteran is
sukhasana let's grab this guy here do I
prefer blitz or bullet yeah I prefer
bullet a lot not really that fond of
blitz but for streaming I guess I prefer
blitz okay this just works so let's play
that alright let's get our queen into
the game and that's that's it for this
for this game yeah very nice alright
yeah III can try bullet never I have a
new mouse so I don't know how that will
work out but okay let's let's try bullet
game against mister combo breaker
when will I make another subscribers
arena I'll try to do it for
soon when would you guys want one it's
not another problem
Versace from Portugal okay I don't know
if mr. combo breaker is here doesn't
seem so it says I got mattress dreaming
here that's that's nice
did YouTube subs get me a new house no
now this is a this is a rented place
yeah yeah replacing the dog with a mouse
that's that's it I don't think mr. combo
breaker is here so we're gonna just
accept another challenge don't know if
there's a if there's a bullet to
challenge you anywhere but yeah there is
one okay mr. new BGM I did not move
places I'm still where I was this is
just an additional place I'm using okay
let's capture that guy alright that's a
that's a weird move probably gonna block
with the bishop lights just to grab that
guy here okay that's fair
it's another piece that's a freak Queen
okay I think our our friend here is
playing a bit too fast for even for a
bullet game there's there's no need to
play that fast okay that's mate good
game what's the new Mouse I don't know
it's some speed link mouse that that
changes colors but it is a nice one
all right yeah I mean I do prefer bullet
although it's uh it's harder to read the
chat when I play bullet so analysis and
that gave me I don't think that we well
let's go a five so it's a fun fun thing
to play alright let's try some fun fun
fun moves the fried liver let's go here
it's a funny funny idea maybe maybe it
works who knows ok it works again this
game mr. Trapp aureus that was that was
sneaky of me I admit it but you know
it's a it's chess dream we have to make
it fun alright let's play against mr. M
mgs ok we have the caro-kann that's
always always enjoyable alright but
that's basically I wasn't planning on
doing a long stream or anything I was
just let's go on a g5 just trying to see
if I can make everything work and I'm
very happy at how quickly I got
everything running and yeah we have to
deal with the echo I'm still gonna have
to see how how to deal with that maybe I
should see four maybe maybe not here to
f4
we'll see yeah that sounds like like an
idea yeah very happy about that
okay that's fine h6 why not
why not g5 I just like Knight g5 so you
either like it or you don't
oh let's go let's go here
yeah I can change the picture depending
on the saga that does sound like a plan
definitely
okay he's probably ready to push here so
let's just escape and then try and get
pieces activated okay let's go rookie
one need the emoji pillow yeah I still
have a lot to deal around here so sounds
me deeper I guess you were trying to say
that the microphone sounds deeper don't
think it's possible as it's the exact
same Mouse yeah probably gonna have to
do something about it not sure if I will
be using any phone to deal with the echo
probably I'm pretty sure there's like a
filter for open broadcasting software
that deals with the echo all right G 5
why not
yeah the g5 sounds nice probably g4 as
well
yeah his king is much safer than my king
let's just get my queen away from here
and I'm trying to get Knight e5 in okay
yes you have to deal with that let's go
Bishop e3 first also maybe harass this
pawn here that's nice yeah there is no
super chat superjet is not available in
Croatia it's a nice country in all but
you know you don't have super chat
alright it's a nice nice move with the
night
let's prevent that okay let's let's go
here
Secor king yeah all right we're doing
good on time here so yeah I don't want
to allow this capture although I don't
have much options you're gonna play g4
although I don't like it and then maybe
move the bishop to g3 and then see what
happens
start pushing the others no other way
around it
let's go back here okay that was fast
b5 yeah b5 was probably even even better
there's no way to defend the knight now
hmm not the best okay fair enough
nope not gonna let you capture there
okay push that guy probably III not
available yeah he's better but he is
done on time so that's how it usually is
yeah let's push here push further I have
to open some lines here if we are to
achieve anything okay that's fair I
guess oh yeah I missed that wow that's
that's insane
oh that's that's really a shame hmm I'm
just game man good game still gonna try
and trick him although it's it's that's
impossible to do it from this position
yeah there's no way to do it
the shop here yeah that's game game man
that is good game alright alright yeah
that's always always why I dislike the
French and the caro-kann it's always
tricky to play against against those
guys
what does a gun matter meaning creation
that's that's a that's the biggest
secret there is all right
yeah not a bad game not a bad game at
all black really really played well
Wilson the chess hustler would have won
probably probably Wilson can grab two
pieces at once yeah I can try and play
the Evans gambit if my opponent you know
proceeds with the Italian but yeah if
you if you guys would enjoy a nice arena
we can we can do that another problem
yeah yeah it's close mr. mr. Caesar but
but not quite sure thing mr. mr. McGee
ax all right mr. Ben Lucas okay we're
gonna see a queenside castle once again
but it's a bit a bit different now or
maybe not maybe not oh yeah the live the
live lags but it's not it's not an
actual lag it's a delay so people I
don't know if it has any use with chess
but you know with with other games there
there is a use for this next Friday okay
we're gonna consider an Ice Arena for
next Friday
sure let's push b5 some more
maybe even push a six and go queen F or
something like that
do I get bitcoins from my link I didn't
get some yeah but not not in a very long
time okay hmm not what I was hoping for
but still it's it's okay I guess
there's no good way for him to push here
captures captures play with marks 13
okay I will try to find find a person
with that name no homie I do not live in
Russia I'm from Croatia okay what do we
play here let's go back you're missing a
few videos by alpha zero no I did not
delete any okay he's threatening to
capture my knight there which is not a
problem I'm gonna capture his knight and
then have a nice discovery I don't have
a sim title and leeches because my title
is a national one not an international
one so we just only allows international
titles
okay let's trade this guy here he can't
push because we have a much more
pressure on the f4 square so there's no
danger of g4 ever so it's not a problem
hmm okay f6 so weird move as it hangs a
knight but I guess it's fine I think he
just overlooked that yeah okay now if
I've prevents me from capturing but
still
might even just capture here it's also a
possibility okay yeah let's just capture
here should be it should be fine
yes see Anissa is a feed a title but
it's also a national one so so there's
that chocolate is just trade here and we
should be good let's play something like
this whoa that's that's incredible I
just overlooked a hole Queen sorry about
that really I was just planning to trade
everything down and and have an easy
ending but I overlooked the Queen yeah
it does happen and my opponent overlooks
one back this is this is one insane game
this is one insane game Wow there's
nothing worse than overlooking the Queen
and then your opponent does the same
yeah okay let's try and get our King
into the game okay
yeah I was a really really really a sad
thing to do
alright let's push there
[Music]
[Music]
okay that was a I was very very that was
bad that was just bad you know but what
are you gonna do okay
a nice bullet to relax yeah that was an
advanced queen trade Achilles mr. Hill
is thirty all right
it doesn't seem mystery list this year
so we're gonna have to have to play a
different person unfortunately let's go
with who's first
first is okay this is a no time limit
this is 3 plus 3 this is 3 am i hitting
the gym no not really
I wish I was but I'm not yeah that Queen
loss was not good I know that I just
drop a challenge and there are 200
challenges at the moment so we're gonna
try and grab a few more and then after I
could if everything is okay with with
the setup I'm gonna try and work a bit
on the interface although I prefer it
minimalistic but maybe we can also
include something else but I think this
is okay and after after that you know
should be fine okay so we're getting
some play here I'm just gonna trade
everything and get this night over to f6
after everything is traded and it's all
you can hope with black yeah that was a
gentleman Queen return not a mistake I
agree with you Lucian actually it was a
very gentlemanly thing to do that's a
pawn blunder okay you could go Queen it
for Czech but still
another problem 24 check we can trade
well with my earpiece now I'm not in
Zagreb now what do we play here yeah I
guess we trade can go into the end game
can i play some music in the background
no as this is not twitch a YouTube does
not allow music in the background and
now capture with the King okay King is
an active piece in the end game so let's
just activate it okay
the other group can go there it's not
not an issue let's play this first I
know I should develop other pieces but I
like this yeah but now a lot of you know
famous streamers from twitch or or
switching over to mixer so who knows how
how the future will unwind it's too
empty yeah I'm sure it is we're gonna
we're gonna pick up on that okay let's
go f6 prevented the knight from jumping
into the game he's gonna check me we're
gonna trade some rooks it should be nice
I'm up on the clock it's not a problem
looks too clean okay we're gonna take
that into consideration
yeah it's not good if it's too clean
yeah I know we're gonna deal with the
echo somehow and have to ask an echo X
person okay it's a move
I'm gonna try and get my night somehow
over here and create something like that
but then see five maybe is see five
yeah see five could be dangerous okay if
knight Knight e4 c5 could be annoying
wasted a lot of time on that one
hmm yeah we're gonna we're gonna
definitely mix it up a bit so okay let's
go here mc5 now see 5 kind of allows me
maybe maybe we'll see yeah of course
he's not gonna allow me to trade let's
just grab here and go here defend
hopefully he can blunder with rook here
would be nice but I think he's gonna
play something else okay that's nice
that's nice let's get our knight into
the game also maybe some checkmating
ideas are in order although not with the
bishop here regarding this we're okay
let's remover let's go back but not all
the way I guess yeah we can trade pretty
much everything here this Knight is
annoying here are attacking my pawn here
not really okay he grabs Wow he could
have captured my knight here and his
game over now he just blundered that's
shame he really had that one in the bag
so say really a shame for him okay push
yeah nights are tricky nights are tricky
oh yeah we have to go after that one
there's no way around it
nights are tricky bastards okay
okay that was a not the cleanest way but
I saw he was a very low on the clock so
yeah
yeah no that's not a quota nights are
tricky bastards there that's that's for
sure
okay I am learning the chess all right
mister I'm learning the chess
let's let's play a nice relaxing bullet
game alright let's see what we have here
yeah if we play a 10-minute game then we
will only be able to play a game or two
Thank You mr. plow okay thank you
it's a new setup so I am you know still
needs a lot of work hopefully I'll be
able to improve on that yeah but what is
relaxing hyper bullet can be stressful
but bullet is very relaxing okay so I
just capture here once transfer the
Bishop to d3 so maybe he's gonna trade
but if he doesn't I will definitely
trade let's go here threaten the bishop
I really wouldn't mind capturing that
yeah okay it's fair let's do it like
this if he trades now I have the d6
square which is a very nice square what
is the knight doing there that's I could
also grab the rook does he have a maid
threat no he doesn't it's a really weird
night maneuver okay so the queen is safe
but we do grab the rook you can have
that guy yeah it's not a problem
let's threaten this knight Knight of six
now we go here force him to react
somehow nope
he doesn't okay let's go
here I don't mind if he captures he's
just gonna double up his pawns so it's
not a problem but usually when I talk a
lot I blunder apiece so maybe I should
just play yeah let's go here let's push
the pawn okay not all the way there I
guess maybe not the greatest way to do
it okay
well alright still had one one
millisecond a self-driving car so I can
watch our collateral life on my commute
yeah I know if you if you drive to work
a lot it can be you know if you don't
have anything to do on your drive can be
annoying mr khan's
see
under and and and and and thank you
mister Thank You mr. high-tech ender
where is the new place the new place is
very near my old place but it's it's not
like a new that I replaced it with this
place is just an additional place that
will will not be used for recording or
streaming unless in emergencies but
mostly for the for the creation of our
new chess manga so that that's where I'm
playing chess also in my hometown so
it's actually like a five minute walk
from where I live
okay this is a Tremont three minute game
so what's the story with Michael tall
there's no story with me hotel it's just
the way it is ah yeah it's definitely
time for that I see a lot of you are
mentioning the echo but there's no way
around it for the moment I will try to
improve on it so so thank you for all of
the suggestions okay what's good no
let's get the rope into the game maybe
go 95 next no I'm not building a new PC
it's already oh sorry about that
the bishop is annoying oh yeah mr. Taba
Sharma I am from Croatia
I think thanks for asking what is the
knight doing here it's a really weird
night capture capture let's trade here
and now we go here no we don't know we
don't on what website am i playing it's
leeches leeches org
I think it also says so in the in the
title of my video yeah if you're a
stream run leeches use which has that
work and then
you are automatically highlighted I
think in their website okay so what do
we have here
I'm just automatically moving pieces
just a normal position I guess where
black is perfectly fine so then I have
to gonna have to try and do something
nice here
yeah some super exciting game as a new
place like I said yeah we're not gonna
be doing the recording here it's mostly
for the creation of the manga and for
emergencies you ever have a picture with
Tao I have to play like Todd well I did
a few games ago I sacrificed my queen
and it was really really awesome okay
what is the queen doing attacking my
rope here not very happy about that
definitely definitely not happy about
that so how do we proceed I guess we
trade and play g3 it is a weakening but
it's not another terrible weakening I
want to play f4 she has a great night
here we're gonna have to figure out how
to get around that yeah let's push h4
instead try and get that point of the
board okay let's go here now I might
even start pushing on the King side he
still has a minute I'm gonna wait for
him to get lower than a minute just to
really start pushing let's play a 5
maybe maybe g4 next or maybe just
improve the position of the King a bit
like this it's too much faster than me
yeah okay he's going for the pawn not a
problem I don't mind the pawn let's go
g4 he's gonna grab the pawn okay it's a
fair fair deal let's go here okay I have
to capture I didn't really think this
through a lot
yeah that's pretty sad I can't even move
mm yeah that's that's pretty bad
bring back the handlebar mustache yeah
he's just trade now as he so much up on
the clock but he doesn't okay he just
gave me a chance here I guess yeah I
just had hugged my knight he missed it
okay well I guess you know one sees
everything yeah that's that's a shame
Queen xb1 yeah Queen xb1 moves sound
like crystal glass pieces okay there are
still a lot of things we have to we have
to improve on but this is the first
stream here so okay let's see someone
from the bottom of the list
wow it's it's a really long list okay
hmm
okay mr. three-plus Oh
yeah there was a bigger blunder than
Maria almost as but I have played a much
stronger opponent Magnus at age 15 oh
that's a that's a big task no no I
haven't haven't even tried it at age 15
mm-hm okay let's try a nice b4 Sicilian
no it's not true that I scratched my
ankle when I say sorry about that
I actually fixed the sound okay so we
win a piece here so it's uh it's always
nice to win a piece that's a nice piece
let's go here and together King to
safety as soon as possible you know
being up a piece is not everything okay
wanna get the Queen away from there get
the bishop into the game and hopefully
trade that guy okay the rook is ready to
enter the game I like it what is the
manga rights uh it's a comic book we're
gonna be doing the further promote chess
is gonna be really awesome so hope you
guys are ready for that what is the new
set up well the new set up is is really
awesome so let's move our King to be one
is there a chance of you playing yeah
there is I don't know how long I will be
here I really this don't really have a
lot of time today I just want to see if
everything works the video the audio
manga about chess yes I'm very glad
you're interested about that okay Queen
captures now he will play f6 I guess or
9h8 how does he prevent mate
yeah f6 it's not the greatest way of
doing things
do I want to capture here I guess I do I
can give check
and then bring the bishop to be three
hmm
94 yeah I guess I guess it's all right
here right c4 and now I guess I start
pushing and try and open the position up
okay so I don't have any good tricks
here but I do win more material so I
guess I'll go for that
how do you get rid of Chet why would you
get rid of Chet that's what what life's
dream is for you want to chat with other
people
my opponent offers a draw and he resigns
well if it was not a rating game I would
definitely offer a draw good game mr.
Spock do I have any friends in Iraq well
I don't have any friends in Iraq as I've
never been there but I do have I do have
some acquaintances can i splits game mr.
magic roll 'some ah you don't see the
screen when at full screen on your phone
that's that's really weird that
shouldn't happen okay let's go if 5c4
maybe so yeah okay you can have that I'm
just gonna play rocky 1 that's an ice
queen let's go here and capture capture
okay so we're doing okay here that's one
way to do it I guess let's go here okay
so threatened okay that's another free
piece if the rook comes we're just gonna
grab that check here check here
get the knight into the game and yeah I
don't have a finisher here okay I do
have it now let's go here capture here
and if he captures the knight we capture
f7 no he doesn't he wants to checkmate
me nope not happening yes you will have
to oh you don't wanna capture it okay
we'll go G for now you have to capture
it and now we push kh4 here and that's
well it's good actually I had no I have
no idea how he how he was able to escape
that really really was hoping that's
made the chat doesn't allow you to see
the chessboard when it's fullscreen on
my phone I have no idea why that is
unfortunately I'm not a chat ex expert
but I've never actually seen that the
best Sicilian variation for black
well if you ask Carlsen and you know
regarding the World Chess Championship
match is the sveshnikov but I I really
enjoyed the night off so okay what are
we doing here yeah play classically I
don't think we'll be playing a lot of
classical on stream okay it's a nice
Queen treat I guess yeah it's not not
the best
yeah let's let's try this when you turn
the phone sideways the chat covers the
screen I'm pretty sure there's a like a
button that allows you to get rid of the
chat not sure but I'm pretty sure juries
yeah I am from Croatia yeah definitely
people say if you hold it vertically
there's an X at the top so it shouldn't
be a problem
okay that's a nice night I guess we we
what we capture it okay
not a problem okay we go here he did to
grab a pawn there so that's nice yeah
you should be able to figure it out it's
a shouldn't be a problem
okay so what's happening here nothing
much we're still the material is equal
all the pieces are equal so this is this
will be a good game let's get our roots
into the game I don't even mind trading
yeah okay at the moment i said that i
blundered a pawn
yeah it's even better
that's even better Wow let's try this
should work try and kick it away from
there he's gonna grab pawn and I don't
really have a good follow up here so I
guess I'm just trying to confuse him
here
okay I like that that's that's great
actually
Wow
[Music]
that's actually really great yeah this
blunders this blunders the game so not
happening yeah I guess I have to admit
that I belong to the poll for now and he
really keeps on improving the position
that's really awesome captures captures
captures and he's gonna capture with the
meat threat that's very nice really
really enjoy that
so gonna have to go into an end game up
on down but it's a night against the
bishop I'm gonna try and be tricky if he
goes rook e1 I guess King your faith
should be possible it's very strong okay
yeah and now he doesn't capture I don't
know why or I'm missing something but
that was a perfectly nice bond okay
let's keep the night away
yeah sorry bishop well I three more in
the future well I do enjoy streaming so
I guess it is possible although not sure
if I will be doing it very often I wanna
play a four yeah he makes room for the
bishop so not gonna play a four now
although I wouldn't mind if he just
moves the bishop okay if he moves it all
the way then check picks up the point
you're gonna put my phone to a light
square I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna try and
win this since I have so much time okay
now we play another pawn and we go after
this guy maybe maybe not let's just push
here
okay that's a that's a pond that's what
I wanted to grab ah let's capture and
push now let's grab another one even
better okay that's why nights are tricky
bastards they always manage to win
against the ships you know most of the
time okay I almost blunder chiqing gear
six
blunders of the night so let's just push
this point okay let's grab that guy yeah
it's nice
okay that was good that was good
he's gonna play Bishop here to try and
trick me no he won't
okay good game that was a very nice nice
end game is rocky are better than rocky
I don't know I don't know what the rocky
is but I do know what rakia is should I
shoot claw dare we have a man there
there's your sheriff yeah yeah my old
Sarah was unassailable laughs thanks man
this is not the new set up this is just
the one I'm using at the moment beer of
choice Bureau of choice Krisha logic oh
of course
what's next after the capablanca saga
that's up to you we're gonna have a nice
poll as always and then you were you're
going to be able to to vote on it as
usual
okay
no no I'm not going to put metal in the
box behind me no and don't worry okay
we're gonna go for the full beer counter
gambit it's always a fun thing to play
yeah it's it's not another apartment
it's just a different space I'm using at
the moment for the creation of the chest
manga like we said no I don't play
League of Legends anymore I used to I
wouldn't say I played it I just spent a
lot of time playing it never really
improved I just you know I was I was
able to reach gold and that's about it
alright I got into promotion for
platinum but never reached it thoughts
on the budget defense very nice very
enjoyable defense okay this is really
not neither of us is trying to achieve
anything from the opening this is this
is good stuff okay he wants to trap my
bishop I don't know if I would play that
g4 I'm gonna capture g4 I don't mind
giving up a piece for that okay with the
bishop there I don't mind
Bishop c5 check it's gonna be very
unpleasant for him to even try and play
this King here gonna give a check if not
Queen h4 I think that it's safe to
assume this is game here she wants to
give a rope that's that's fine
nope okay it's interesting to say the
least
let's get the Queen into the game
Queen g6 followed by Queen g2 if he
doesn't prevent it I know I haven't
tried playing go but I will I would like
to try it someday
especially if if someone who knows how
to play it would would introduce me to
it
my first chest role model well of course
Michael Tao first end and always do I
play Starcraft no I don't but I did I
tried playing it yesterday although not
not like against someone for real but
the D arcade mode that was kind of nice
ok how will you play this I guess
check-check King III yeah I guess he's
surviving that tile or even cook well
both of them are really awesome awesome
guys although chuck is still being alive
you know both of them really awesome
dudes let's check here check there he's
gonna go to e3 then I guess maybe rook
e8 shouldn't it should be nice rook e8 I
guess yeah rook e8 is nice mhm
no don't spam hash tick-tock come on
don't be like that
thanks mr. Alex I wish thanks man a mr.
dan user no don't spam that ah you don't
send a super jet we don't have super jet
in Croatia okay how do we win this now a
nice discovered Trek night blocks route
captors mate that's what I want to see
that's what I want to see night blocks
only move and rook no he resigned before
I delivered me it's not fair but okay
yeah guys that's that's it for the
stream like I said I just wanted to
check out if everything was working
properly so if I need to do an emergency
stream or an arena I'm unable to do it
from my apartment
maybe my neighbors are noisy or they're
you know constructing something anything
can happen
then I always have a have an alternative
a but yeah this is basically I could
move the camera around if you want to
see the setup yeah well I want to do it
since you know you guys can check out
where the manga is being created this is
the setup okay so let's see there we
have it a lot of boxes around here there
are some okay still yeah there we have
it there this is the the place where the
setup is being created sorry since the
manga will be created there's another PC
here there's teen chick there we have it
Tina is working hard on the under manga
and that's about it yeah so hope you
enjoy that but yeah I like to sit I do
hope you enjoyed it I will see you soon
and hopefully we're gonna have some some
more nice dreams like this well fairly
soon so think I'll and I will see you
soon and a good game everyone